isn't it a beautiful day well yes it
certainly is
I thought I'd play a little golf this
morning oh well good for you got a nice
day for it the only thing is though I've
never played before do you know anything
about the game oh well I I wouldn't go
so far as to say that I've played at it
for quite a few years
oh I bet you played beautifully Oh what
made you say that I don't know you just
look like the athletic type oh well
actually a golf is I mean it's it's a
strange sort of a game yes they say that
putting is the most important part of
the game well well all the strokes are
important of course it is true if you
want to score a while you've got a putt
well ah isn't that cute uh what is what
you just said if you want to score one
you've got a putt well oh I must
remember that look you want to score
well you've got a hot wet blood you have
a pencil I'd love to write that down
Oh actually it is not complicated all
you do is just tap the ball into the cup
would you show me please
you seem to make everything sound so so
interesting are you expecting someone
well I wasn't expecting my Maya caddy
well okay I just tapped the ball
cup here okay are you watching me yes
yes I I'm watching a my pending over far
enough uh you know I I would say you are
definitely not coming from this angle oh
[Music]
oh I didn't do that very well at all did
I well that wasn't too bad because you
you you hit the ball a little too hard
see you have to stroke it firmly but but
gently would you show me pain well no
don't do grip the club this is this is
my cat my yeah my wife this this is the
the young lady I I wasn't telling you
about Louise I think we're making a
mistake Lester and Earl will be furious
when they find out about this
let him be furious I want to get a look
at Carl before that party tonight I want
to know how I'm going to stack up but we
just spent three hours at the beauty
parlor you look gorgeous
so do you but maybe pearl of super
gorgeous please be sensible
our husbands knew this woman years and
years ago do you realize how old she
must be by now I hear they start very
young back in those hills now we've come
this far
I'm not leaving until I've seen pearl
but this is gonna be very embarrassing
she's gonna think we're a couple of
Snoopy worried wives aren't we oh yeah
that's good look Gladys if it'll make
you feel any better we won't tell her
who we are we'll say we're a couple of
those sub house-to-house cosmetic sales
women but you'll find out who we are the
party they will all have a good laugh
over it now come on
oh hi dinner ladies come in come in
thank you
what kind of for you we're selling
cosmetics you're selling what cosmetics
you know beauty cream face powder
perfume oh thank you lady but I never
use it
to the lady of the house and we
understand a lady named pearl is here
yeah yeah she's your dad yeah yeah I
need your help
huh get it oh I didn't know your head
company are you pearl
please be pearl well I ain't who are you
please lady sells beauty cream granny oh
you can see I don't need none kid I need
you well probably down directly she
comes down them stairs every five
minutes wearing a different beautiful
gown she's trying to pick one for the
wingding tonight Hey
[Music]
daddy did y'all think this dress is
fancy enough for a wingding well back to
the beauty shop
[Music]
uh I beg your pardon would you mind
telling me your name please well not at
all it's Benson
Eddie Benson no Barbara you know you're
about the 10th man that's asked me my
name tonight oh well I guess they
thought you were the mystery shopper too
well I don't know one of them asked me
at the bus stop and two others asked me
outside the store oh I'm not the mystery
shopper in fact I'm looking for myself
oh well have you had any luck not yet
I've got a pretty good method though
every woman I look at I try to visualize
with that black hood on have you tried
that oh well it sounds like a good idea
why don't you try it on this lady over
here
oh well hello oh hi
I wonder why she bought the baseball bat
[Music]
that's not all castle is fun now before
we go on with our discussion I think we
should pause long enough to extend the
hearty greeting to the husbands who were
kind enough to join us this evening
[Applause]
[Music]
madam chairman I understood that all the
husbands were gonna be here tonight
clifford sit down I just wanted to find
out sit down Clifford yes my dear you
get home boy will I tell her off let's
keep the meeting under control now we
all want our dance Saturday night to be
the most successful we've ever given I
must admit that the tickets have been
going very slowly so far but we're
hoping for a lot of last-minute
reservations now does anybody have any
ideas madam chairman yes double I think
most of you ladies know that I used to
be in show business now I realized that
this idea of mine might be a little bit
out of season but I think we have so
many very attractive Club members I was
thinking it might be a lot of fun if we
had a bathing beauty contest
in connection with the death of course
most ridiculous idea I've ever heard I
gotta have a pie-eating contest would
you like to make a motion oh not without
my costume in mind my music all those in
favor of a bathing beauty contest say
aye
baby beauty contest is a good idea but
we ought to wait until summertime so now
that makes some sense does anybody else
have any ideas well madam chairman I'd
like to make a motion about balloon I
beg your pardon
well I think without considerably to the
gaiety of the occasion along about
midnight we had a great fanfare of
trumpets and released hundreds of
balloons
well thank you during my undergraduate
days of a sir we had some really gay
parties and they always featured
balloons at midnight of course that was
a few years ago you can say that again
did you say something Clifford I think
it's a splendid idea thank you
well there's just one thing can we get
enough balloons on such short notice
oh yes I'm I'm quite sure we can you see
my sister's husband happens to be in
that business as a matter of fact I have
a few samples right here if you can't
see one I have sufficient wind to blow
them up is she kidding well maybe one of
the husband's a volunteer how about mr.
Nelson
[Music]
if this is some sort of a sobriety test
I can assure you ladies I drink nothing
stronger than coca-cola that's a pretty
big balloon I hope I can handle it go
ahead dear I'm sure your Wendy enough
laughs : pigeon Yosh Locke like this
comes along maybe once in a lifetime
people he must have been living right
huh here we got the deal all set and
along comes his backward frontman a
natural lowly guy no friends nobody
remembers him well you'll be so glad to
have some pals E he'll do anything I
don't go for it we spent a lot of time
case in this caper I'm gonna do it
myself
we can't trust a guy we don't know we
can't trust that face of yours they'd
know 'litham energy end of the bank same
bye Mike sit down what about Louie he's
from out of town nobody knows him
Louie you've got to give lawyer your cut
for Lloyd you understand with this
citizen that Mike's talking about we
came at all tax-free yeah the bank
guards wise up and get itchy finger as
well that's Tom John's funeral our only
expense is sending flowers well what
about Marie and me it's our funeral - we
got a stake in this thing yeah how about
our trip to Paris if this joker doesn't
do the job right where are we back in
Brooklyn yeah relax baby in a week
you'll be centering down the Champs de
Lizzy I guarantee
where did you leave our new partner the
barbershop the manicurist probably
working on his left hand by now take him
by the right Milito up here right but
[Music]
Forrest's you know the rules thanks
though but that's not like a bribe or
anything dishonest that's sweet it's a
rule how you getting on well I went to
that place you said about the job and
the man thought I wasn't the type for it
but he wanted me to go out with him I
didn't though so now me and mother are
making this hook run for our floor do
you know how to roll clothes and stuff
I'm sorry about the job hello Mary where
I all right stay there don't move Mary
do you hear me just sit right there and
stop being hysterical Oh Florence we'll
have to figure out a job you're the type
for in the meantime you just keep right
on with that hook road
why you must have known even if you
hadn't called it was only a matter of
time before you would have been caught
what did you think would happen
I don't know what do you think will
happen now
I'll go back to prison that's what I
deserve
we'll see about that I must say you've
got good taste in clothes I'm taking you
down to jail you think about the best
way to handle this and why you did it
I'll do some thinking too
[Music]
I've got her in the county jail on
suspicion of parole violation I can hold
a 72 hours without filing sending her
back to prison solve anything if it
would we'd have no need for parole if we
had more psychiatric help at the
institution it would be different but we
haven't and that's what she needs she
turned herself in she hasn't touched any
of the merchandise it's all recoverable
and the store's Protective Association
have agreed not to prosecute I admit
they didn't like it but they agreed so
many of our girls need psychiatric help
why do you think this one's special
because basically she is special
I'm sure this girl can be helped at
least I'm sure it's worth a try with
your permission I'd like to continue her
parole status
so you are punishing yourself by
deliberately flaunting the law getting
yourself arrested the fine clothes you
wanted for your wedding the champagne
you didn't have with him even the hotel
where you were to stay I killed him
you both acted childishly what happened
isn't your fault it wasn't his we lost a
lot of men in Korea but their deaths
weren't the fault of women who didn't
marry them you have your own life to
live marry torturing yourself won't
bring him back
look
where I stand I think you've done a
wonderful job how do you feel about it
she's gained a good deal of insight in
these past few months learn to face
reality I don't think you'll have any
more trouble good she finishes her
parole next month I'll see you a couple
of times more there are a few minor
things we haven't worked through the
manager the restaurant tells me she's
the best host to see ever head she's had
two raises I appreciate what you've done
Vic you very fond of this girl aren't
you the daughter you never had I felt
from the start you were making a
personal identification but now look
don't try to get me as a patient I'm
doing alright as I am leave well enough
alone
yeah that copy stays with us and that's
yours
there's your gold seal that makes you a
free woman marry a citizen again you go
back to acting now
I don't know I'm happy where I am I
don't think I'll make a change just yet
and being in the restaurant business has
certain advantages over acting
can always eat but the main advantage
and being off parole is I can see you
now as a trend this is a chapter of your
life that's closed and I'm part of that
chapter the best thing you can do is to
forget all about it make a new life for
yourself
airy
marry Robert you've gotten over that the
memories behind you again and forget
about him
forget me forget prison and parole as
the best baby you can do me and yourself
[Music]
Thank You mrs. crow
[Music]
well girl good morning morning Sally
have a nice weekend I sure did I slept
Oh mrs. Karlsen about that last job you
sent me irises just got to be something
other type for well figure out what it
is well I check my mail
Sally when did this come it was under
the door this morning lieutenant and
mrs. William Harris requests the honor
of your presence for luncheon at the
Tower Hotel at 12 o'clock she's not your
responsibility any longer she's off
parole I better go after all she never
sent out invitations before
[Music]
you're early
Am I I'm afraid I'm too late you better
let me in Mary when was the last time
you saw dr. banner I don't know week or
more ago so much has happened certainly
has hello I'm Bill Harris Harris but I
thought you were dead I spent two years
nine months and 28 days in a prison camp
there were times when I thought so too
I needed Carlson I'm Mary's aunt I just
dropped by all right
Carlton bill knows all about me and I
know all about you how he talks with
nothing else don't bill everything I
don't want there to be any more
misunderstanding
ever we understand each other perfectly
after all you know I was in prison too
good news for you my love what is it my
darling
it's something the doctor examined me
this morning and he said Oh myself
you'll be the happiest man in the world
oh my love you don't mean you can't mean
yes my love the doctor told me he take
my cast off in two months
Jonathan you'd be so lonely
and there's nothing I can do ours is
Trula I can never be lonely when my
thoughts are of you all day and all
night I think of nothing but your late
golly Dex isn't he faithful would you be
that faithful to me if I broke my leg oh
sure I would Corliss I love you oh you
just saying that break your leg and I'll
prove it
please be honest with me Jonathan I must
know
I can't Louise I simply can't you must
tell me Jonathan
we've always been truthful with each
other please Jonathan please tell me
well the doctor said he'd have to break
your leg and reset it again oh goodness
I thought it was something serious
you can't take this attitude Louise
you've got to walk you must please try I
can't I can't I know it can oh no it's
still the same so I can get
I can't admit defeat now I've been
through too much remember I love you
Jonathan I'm afraid I can't you will you
will you have the courage try for me
Jonathan
both my legs are broken try never mind
get it come to me do it for our love
walk to me try my beloved can't try even
though your legs are broken try try
Oh Jonathan Jonathan I want a rope Oh
Jonathan love conquers all
everybody ready just about to Arles
Texas here let's go all right pal be
nice to get out for a change we've been
watching too much television lately Oh
it'll be fun the first time in weeks
I bet it'll be a good show well let's go
you don't want to miss the beginning
here we go
we's my love what happened when I left
yesterday you were walking my darling
the most terrible thing I was showing
the doctor how strong my leg was and it
broke again will you please not call me
again I don't want to talk to you I beg
your pardon is this mrs. Stephens oh
excuse me I thought yes this is mrs.
Stephens I'm Sondra Adams mrs. Henry
Adams my husband met you last evening
and he thought it a good idea for me to
call you I looked your number up in the
telephone book he hopes you understand
his motive in talking to you
you see he's told me about your unhappy
situation and I wanted you to know that
we'd both like to help divorce is an
unhappy experience at best but it's so
much easier to bear when we can share
the burden and I think we can help you
mrs. Stephens would you talk to my
husband for a moment he's right here I
hope you'll forgive this call mrs.
Stephens it's quite all right mr. Adams
but how can you help me are are you a
lawyer yes I am a lawyer I specialize in
divorce cases
well since you feel as you do and your
husband will undoubtedly do the same
thing to you again I suggest you make it
a clean break when I come to my office
and talk it over oh I'm sure we can help
you through this thing so that there'll
be no fanfare no nasty publicity fine
I'll see you at 3 o'clock
goodbye mr. Stephens
ten affidavits at $75 each for decrees
to deliver that's $1,000 and that would
are incidental collections is a total of
$1,900
how much do we got in the kitty not
about 32,000 well we better move on as
soon as we hit 35,000 the Stevens case
will just do it what do you think I say
move on our Luck's been too good to hold
in this town all right we'll leave the
end of the week oh by the way I'm
getting the Stephens for another hundred
dollars each this afternoon want to take
care of this hello mr. Stephens
this is Henry Adams we just received
some news about your case I wondered if
you could stop by the office uh hi and
I'll expect you later this afternoon
goodbye so you see mrs. Stephens we've
jeopardize your entire case if we fail
to republish your divorce notice for two
weeks is the court-ordered it's only an
additional hundred then I had no idea
this would be so costly you say I have
to pay 250 more for the decree well
that's only standard mrs. Stephens if it
works a hardship on you I'm sorry but
what can I do mr. Adams this hundred I
just gave you makes a total of four
hundred and fifty how much is mrs.
Stephens giving you oh I I couldn't say
offhand I'd have to check my records but
I think I can say that you're almost off
the hook I mean you'll have your decree
in a few days and after all mrs.
Stephens isn't asking for alimony and
now you want another 250 before you
deliver the decree
oh well that's standard mr. Stephens how
do I know that this divorce will be
recognized in this state doesn't seem
possible that one can get a divorce
without either party being present huh
what do you don't know your Constitution
do you guarantees that it says every
state will guarantee Full Faith and
Credit to every other state it's solid
mr. Stephens absolutely solid you
haven't got a thing to worry about
well I've I've got to be getting back to
my office today mr. Stephens today
hello Lori I've got to talk to you can
you meet me in the coffee shop around
the corner well it's about this Adams
I think we ought to compare notes all
right in 20 minutes it's 400 and my 450
makes 850 dollars we've given Adams and
we're supposed to shell out 250 more
apiece for the decree Lori I snowed a
rat the minute I met this Adams I think
it's a racket of some kind Oh Dan it's
all my fault if if only I hadn't gone to
him only you hadn't gone to anyone oh
now now honey don't cry we work this
thing out but how what do we do now
we'll find a way in the meantime let's
be thankful we found out we were making
a mistake and that's the situation John
Adams expects us in his office at 10
o'clock tomorrow with our money to pick
up our decrees obviously the matters in
the confidence game if he's a lawyer
which I doubt he's acting unethically
your decrees won't be worth the paper
they're written on then we just have to
remarry if they were good but other
couples may not be so fortunate he may
have helped to break up a lot of other
homes what do we do now
I have an idea Dan suppose you show up
at Adams office tomorrow alone at 10:00
as you're supposed to pretend that
everything is okay I'll have a surprise
waiting for him that he won't expect all
right I'll leave everything up to you
okay then and now I have some things to
do so I I sure hope that Laurie and I
get back together again soon thanks a
lot John so long so long Dan and keep
your chin up
right well he'll come in Stevens come in
I was just about to telephone you sit
down won't you have an important
appointment away from the office of
about 10:30 and I wanted to be sure you
hadn't forgotten this was the big day
your wife intends to show up didn't she
no no mrs. Stevens couldn't come with me
I'll have to take her copy for her well
you have the money I mean her payment
and yours oh yes I have that here
well in that case I'm sure that I can
give you her copy thank you
you're the Steven secrete hemming Thank
You Sandra there you are sir that's fine
Adams just fine what's the meaning of
this who are you
I'm captain Braddock of the racket squad
sealers files beaters
you're under arrest Adams you too mrs.
Adams if you're his wife which I doubt
you're making a great mistake captain
what are the charges grand theft Bunco
and practicing law without a license are
that's absurd where's your proof I have
all the proof I need and your files will
undoubtedly furnish more I checked with
the Bar Association and you're not even
an attorney
yours is a dirty racket Adams I wouldn't
say that some people want a divorce and
I make it easy for it you think nothing
of destroying the sanctity of marriage
do you all right Dan Laurie you won't be
needed here any longer
oh by the way you're not divorced you
know and this is no place for a second
honeymoon
so hustle along home or we'll want you
to testify in court though we'll be
there John and thanks Shirley hi I I
don't like being stuck with Colette and
Henderson tonight any more than you do
but look if you'll cooperate I'll show
you how we can get rid of them early
really bye
Wow you danced the legs off ahead of him
why me he's collapsed days oh I know
honey but you see all for Colette she
can't do it she's older than you are
oh yeah I thought you wanted to help me
get rid of them early so we could be
alone you know I do oh good then if
you'll help Colette we're down Henderson
huh
Oh dances legs off oh that's my baby oh
hello mrs. helm no taxi your mother just
called looking for you really yeah you
like to use the phone oh yes thank you
would you please give this to Margaret
it's some very special nylon but we've
been looking for everywhere and I
finally found them out in Westwood
you're a mr. Tom
hello mother it's rude he did from a bar
Tommy oh he's with Bob now mother
thank you now let me take care of it
goodbye Tom we'll be right down
Oh Chuck do you happen to know if your
Uncle Bob is double-dating tonight yeah
yeah I heard him pointing to of his
swinging us model do you happen to know
who the other man is well Uncle Bob
referred to him is a big furniture man
but I don't know his name I do by any
chance do you know where they're going
no oh say it seems to me like you
mentioned me the mermaid club the
mermaid Club yeah thanks Chuck
are you leaving oh I'm joining Harvey at
the mermaid Club oh well I hear the four
shows are riot
you'll both have a lot of laughs I
expect Harvey to be in stitches you can
only got him worn down oh that's
wonderful
well like I got the order already I'll
be right over
[Music]
see ya I wonder what have no heart you
don't think he's mad you gals would
rather dance with me huh
- later I guess you stuck with him I
think I have a run in my stocking oh
look hey wave him harm or I was making a
few phone calls
thank good I think of blonde Cooper now
mother surely may be older every time I
visit you so he'll often I catch up with
you would you rather sit this one out
Louie no no it's okay let's go to
cocktail I'll say gaarkhan bring me
another one just like that our second
thought you better make it a fool and
that one's empty
boy he's duller than Collins
[Music]
well hello there this is mr. Helms table
it sure is honey
hey when that hard we make the phone
call he sure gets results Anderson's my
name HR Henderson my friends call me
happy
Oh pair our mr. Hellman mr. Carlin oh
that impalas are just too dull for us
but Oh Harve out that dancing up a storm
with a little French babe I don't see
him well maybe they're sitting this one
out yeah you know no hablo long but not
well where you gonna know him well
before this nights over honey that boy
is faster than a hog heading for a
bullet shitless how many more mad I've
had me some winged into my time but last
night with old Harvey no two gals was
the blue tail fur-covered apple knocking
and he'll last night too
oh how did we had us a ball I tell you
but then he told me he worked late last
night at the office funny you were clean
but not at the oven there yeah would you
like to being sugar well thank you but I
think I'll see if I can find mr. hell oh
[Music]
I don't believe I got your name honey a
mrs. helm yes hell yes
oh that's a lovely name Odie's calif on
you
[Music]
all right you didn't get it wet yo Bobby
I've ever contact already the sign oh
yeah
good evening mr. Claus oh yeah yeah
that's good the table Getti single
weirdo wouldn't your buddy uh mr.
Henderson doesn't like me very well I
think that I'd better wait right okay
you dance with Colette I'll get it
all congratulations Bobby see these mini
big waves for you
Oh mr. blah just one minute I am gonna
be in oh yeah
you know we wouldn't want and get in the
way of our having a good time tonight
would be well no boy why don't we just
get this furniture or sign it out of the
way oh all right that's it
where'd I put that Johnny right on the
top line oh that's cool uh Kevin um
Harvey you married man married me are
you kidding ah what Shirley honey
am I married tell him Mary oh yeah
not yet yeah
must've heard wrong where'd I put it
right on the top line there that's fine
[Music]
what is bocce user oh we are really
putting up an exhibition I haven't seen
anything yeah you sounded just like my
wife
[Music]
that's fine well half
thank you can very much that my pleasure
boy well say yeah can't comes that
little lady who said she was mrs. Hale
MIT mrs. what else my goodness
mother will you ask him to call me as
soon as he comes in okay I just finished
drawing here is calling in New York Gus
I'm writing class vice president helm
which is to speak - well congratulations
higher what are you gonna do celebrate
something I am going out and I'm gonna
buy me the biggest of thick is the
juiciest steak will you join me
you bet I will are oh I need to get
personal boss who gave you the shiner
mother but you are a photographer can
you advance medical science of course in
my own way I hope to make several
advances you be a sweet girl and wait
for me and hopping Vavi
what do you think I call it while you
are with all those doctor honey hmm all
the other the diet oh yes of course
am I your favorite you know you are how
can I you've got more charm more beauty
motion Issaquah more
[Music]
eivol
hi there Shirley my goodness you've been
here long long enough yeah how did you
like my father said to me fine fine but
I like to better last night when you
said it to me what we up scoop oh I'm
done
oh I'm awfully sorry mrs. Livingstone
but but I I forgot to call grandpa
anyway his cameras over to our house so
you just ride over there okay no horse
pulled a flame on me boy oh no she's
free ways out here oh that's stopping
and starting oh I've got a pack a bag
for Palm Springs anyway I'll Drive
Oh Chucky boy say you know it was never
defined Charlie had his phone number so
I'm just gonna hop in the Mitchell and
take it right over to his place you
dudes right here in Hollywood saying
okay grandpa he is here I've got some
wonderful pictures in this album yes
she said hey George
I think there's your picture Charlie hit
this place didn't here's a bass seems to
me a yes sir there it is
that's Jerry Hindi's house it ought to
be a familiar corner do you they say no
no I don't recognize gee mr. Ned get
around much said that their house it's
right on the northwest corner Hollywood
and Vine grandpa doesn't look like that
now no reckon George had it painted let
me come back from Cuba hold him 98
grandpa's gone now
yeah yeah I wish I could bring it back
there fall of 98 well tell you we had
some fun that you yeah you tell your mom
and I've gone over to see daddy well
grandpa wait wait ramp off this picture
60 years old
you bet they don't make pictures like
that nowadays
grandma wait grandpa hello hello this is
Charlie Hanley Josh having coffee right
Oh mr. Hanley wait a minute he just went
out ha ha gee mr. Hindley I'm sorry I
missed him he just drove out say he's
heading for Hollywood and Vine it sounds
silly but he expects to find you there
on the northwest corner the old couch
still likes to give orders yeah
okay I'll be there
bye boy I grandpa must carry a horseshoe
in his pocket daddy
it was nice happy to be waiting out in
front for me there
well I was expecting you Josh but it
sure wasn't expecting this car ain't
seen one like the sneeze hey don't have
a lot of convertibles out here in
California
you sure have fixed up the front of your
house back there on the corner I never
would have noted that so don't live
there in the morgue I show that boy oh
you did yeah 1,900 Oh Charlie you could
have got in 2004 that easy cash money
fellow
ashay 1900 Josh right I don't mean cash
took back a second mortgage a yeah you
never was much of a businessman anyway
Johnny no no you don't yeah what I mean
skipper there yeah where we headed but
we're going to my grand chance to do
picking up a couple of cute little
models Oh Josh you think a couple of
good repair you want to gather the
couple of old fossils what do you mean
old fashioned these girls is young and
pretty
thank you they still say we should have
put on our uniform snatch what gets the
girls hell you know there's any girls to
get God oh there's always your Flocka
females puttering around Robby's roost
such a chip off the old block you know
they stick your head up
well I don't see no females fluttering
or otherwise when you can elicit potato
rape isn't here hmm you mean were dating
a couple pictures
oh you're durn fool these hairdos your
samples
she's women in there oh then what are we
doing out here you know I think we ought
to go put on our uniforms I wanna tell
you it makes the difference between
daylight why don't you go on home
Bob and I have work to do oh don't you
push me you you fat blonde who are you
calling a fat blonde
you look great it was blow for you you
love mouth em - okay is he not bad Josh
okay you take the fat blonde I'll take
the loudmouth okay well then so am I
howdy
you two gals like to step up with us to
finish are you serious
notice we're fun-loving boys right I got
my convertible park down to the curb
take any place you'd like to go they
must be joking
he wouldn't pull our legs would you look
at the road hey no I have other plans so
have I you mean you're turning this down
we yes well m-maybe we don't do we're
girls we'll be right back so when would
you learn to listen to me
if we wore our uniforms then they're
girls that fell all over their shells
trying to get to us
ah how Lois did you ever go into a USO
and try to get a dance without your
uniform we're gonna change right now
yeah that's an order
[Music]
right this way miss old girls look as my
grandfather bit here
boy they were two elderly gentlemen they
try to date you dairy yeah well I was
here all right did they say where they
were going
no but they said they'd be right back ha
ha we got come on let's get set up for
the pictures I'll make him photograph
you all afternoon
[ __ ] please take your phone along with
you - all over again now girl don't you
think I'd love to take you to Palm
Springs but it wouldn't be fair to you
I'm gonna be busy night and day I've got
a thousand things to take care of mm if
I hold up you talk too long that's right
someday it's gonna catch up with you
honey listen
oh you mean yeah well let's hope not
where is that smooth talking brother of
mine he's in the studio look at this
he told me he was going to Palm Springs
to cover a medical convention mm nurses
a beauty contest and Bob's the judge
well he will need those nurses I am
going to be in Palm Springs waiting for
him if I have to Mikey hey you know I
need to thank you
I still say this is just a lot of
lunches yeah will you see how do you
we're back
didn't you say you had a convertible
what would you handsome gentleman drive
us to Palm Springs
please why do you make me wear the chief
coach while she wears a pretty one hmm
terrible uh yeah I think I better
excuses show yours if you wear that coat
the men will look at your face instead
of it because the window shoulder
instead think because you have the most
beautiful face I've ever seen wait with
Jerry's face table you're gonna suck all
right right
cheesy coat beautiful face beautiful car
she's eat my face why for my face get
better that's sure no wait hold it oh
that's what I like about you ladies
you're smart you got a good head on your
shoulders
yeah I know we are both oh yeah solid
uh-huh am I going to see you tomorrow of
course I told you yeah here we are now
from online Facebook what does that mean
telling a blobby uh yeah I think I
better uh excuse us won't you Colette
I'll surely baby what are we trying to
sell with this picture me who buys me
man all right what kind of a face
attracts a man I'm pretty with or as we
say in French fromage face
that's what reminds me that's a
beautiful lovely exciting a beautiful
face the matches sensational coat no
let's get the shot huh
did you talk on that that's why she
couldn't wear the group but I did I
bought her off read thinking about it
she admitted that she was a bonehead
good huh huh can I wear this coat on our
date tonight
are they didn't forgot oh no no no no
honey
eh see it's just that the coast gotta go
back to deferments tonight as long as I
got you you bet you have let's get the
shot fine what do you think I ought to
do about a chance well if I were you
boss I know the window I think that'll
be my best move very good
All Right girls now let's let's try to
get this again now nice big smile that's
it hold it good
[Music]
hi Bobby
ha well what you doing here Bobby tell
me something ah what would you do to
entertain a very important out-of-town
furniture buyer well let me see yeah I
get him a date with a beautiful girl uh
Tama the best night spots wine him and
dine him and before the evening was over
at heavies order for 10 car loads of
pressure Oh Bobby
wonderful Oh Bobby you have saved my job
Oh nonsense are you gotten that advice
from anybody
well advice yes but how many of my
friends would do it for him oh thanks a
million but that's alright um excuse me
look do I understand that you think that
I'm going to entertain you're out of
town and furniture buyer for you
obviously I can't do it the boss would
kill me I'm B what are you talking about
this Bill's up his business I'm talking
about the big big left look walk in oh
you mean the one at home
I love admire enrich me and live in
mortal terror head about rounds oh well
our little lady Henderson's my name HR
Henderson the furniture King I have
stores in five states Bachrach come from
everybody knows and everybody owes HR
Henderson
delighted to make your acquaintance life
life you own or rent rent a furnished or
unfurnished well looks like we can't do
business honey but I have my card anyway
today's acquaintance is tomorrow's
customer say how would you like a
Henderson calendar just zip it open like
that
Oh Oh what do I care fear
maybe you just better have a blotter
honey they told me if mr. Helms office I
could find him here yes he's in the
studio tell me mr. Collins here's a and
I'll bet I know just what they're
talking about to talk about which one of
these lovely ladies are gonna fix me up
a date with tonight
yo I'll tell you us to hell we've never
met but I'd know you anywhere named HR
Henderson oh and I'm delighted to make
your acquaintance and I got a feeling
I'm gonna like your line of furniture
well I'm very glad to know you mr.
Henderson but you see my name is not mr.
Hale if the night right mr. Henderson to
a customer like you he is just plain
Harvey har har but what he likes his
friends you call him I got some mighty
nice friends oh yeah I go I would like
you to meet one of these religious men
in the furniture business mr. H R
Henderson
friends call me HAP tell me somethin
you girls owned a rent that Bobby
probably our lobby I he likes you and he
thinks you're mean Bobby he will have a
wonderful time tonight he'll buy enough
furniture to get me that razor drew he's
been hounding me about please Harv I'm
sorry I I won't do it it's too dangerous
it's too dang ol come on be reasonable
and from that one little old store I'll
built me the biggest credit furniture
business west of the Rocky Mountains
I'll start it with a shoestring and I
wound up with a chain hey how would you
like a hammer some chain honey just take
a look at that holding right up to the
light there and focus it whoops wrong
pocket here's the one for the ladies
right here there you are my dear
everyone for you be my guest honey now
let's see which one you hear I think you
have the fire fall that Yosemite
I say harm yes uh which one of these
gals is my date tonight the blondie or
the Frenchy oh well uh I have a date
with Bob tonight well y'all know he's my
date tonight right movie color Bob you
tell her Harvey yeah I think I better
excuse us just a moment please
oh this what's going on now Shirley baby
I know you're all shook up because you
thought you had a date with me to knock
it but my friend Ravi helm comes first
and his friend mr. Henderson comes even
ahead of him you can say that again boy
I can make a break that man died well no
I don't well if I'm sure that Harvey
will explain it to you in just a half a
minute what are you talking about of
course you're going to be my date
Shirley's with Henderson okay Chloe
Bobby Harvey Harvey Harvey Harvey
what am i a little Dorne
boy you sure are and stay there oh yes
sir mr. Henderson that Harvey helm is a
wonderful fellow but he deserves a much
bigger job that he's got now if you were
to put in a good word with mr. gray blur
about him I'm I'll miss you honey I
missed you honey is this all of the
earth that Harvey now if you were to put
in a good word with mr. gray blur about
him I'm sure that he would be eternally
faithful to you and did it boy you talk
too much why don't you go take a picture
something what are you talking about of
course you're gonna be my date
Colette's gonna be with Henderson okay
sure Bob ah-ha that's right tonight your
heart right and what am i you're my date
I told you that
you know what I want you to call me fat
I don't oh yeah
fromage he says yeah but where did all
those Indians come from well we're all
set up now we'll see these lovely girls
a little later on to see me by half so
long blondie ha
see see Frenchy Oh miss Henson well
would you like us to pick you up tonight
well as soon as you notice me sliding
onto the table did you think that was
funny mister hell oh he didn't hear you
mr. Henderson he said as soon as he
starts sliding under the table that's
better
what that one thing you need the
furniture business it's a sense of humor
so true yes a by the way what line you
pushing this year yeah well I'm having
pretty good success with how'd you like
to be in pictures honey now that's the
kind of thing itself word your boy look
I gotta remember that one for myself
speak well Harvey boy we gonna have
ourselves a carload of fun tonight
oh is this your tummy oh this is daddy
Oh son is daddy honey it is your father
if you turn the television set down
maybe you could hear me
where is mommy they are darling mommy
mommy
your mud daddy's wife Tommy would you
please put your sister on please Tommy
hello Nancy puddin honey this is daddy
darling his mother there she is it
alright alright well look I want you to
take a message for me please
tell mommy the daddy is going to have to
be working late at the or off off off
darling
no net you won't need your secret
squadron decoding ring done Nancy I
Nancy I got Nancy come back surely
you're doing a sensational job of
driving keep your eye on the stud on the
left here Colette not now honey Shirley
knows what she's doing you just keep
your eyes on your side Shirley when we
get the hotel you just pull up in front
and collect since you're sitting on the
right you run in the hotel and get mr.
Henderson why should I go yeah well
we'll be circling the block so we don't
get a parking ticket besides mr.
Henderson will be thrilled to see you
what we're late just to turn in here and
pull up Shirley now will you please
listen carefully dear tell your mother
the daddy is going to be working late at
the office and that I I can't give it to
you in court Nancy I don't know the
secrets but I'm told
that's it magic would you put your
brother back on pleasing to you what do
you mean he just gone down to the
drugstore to buy liver pills I don't
tell us well New York doctors said it
Hey
I believe that good sweet Azusa
Henderson and now Shelley do not try to
steal my day not that you could I like
or concede you could take care of away
from her like that who wants him I've
got you you mean to tell me you're gonna
let her get away with this
look if I was stuck with Henderson I'd
be upset too but surely she challenged
your ability as a woman mm-hmm
forget it let's talk about Ewing me you
have no patriotism hate really this is
bigger than woman against woman this is
France against America you will let your
country down [ __ ] come off it
I know you can't take Henderson away
from her but I don't want to you can I
can now bet the old American spirit all
right all right but I'm not gonna take
him off your hands for the whole evening
well of course not just teach her a
lesson for now how you climb in the back
seat I just want to see the look like
let's face when he climbs in besides
okay good but as soon as we get to the
club I'm getting him back to Colette Oh
naturally honey
[Music]
now them now what I notice that TV is
here to stay
I take every bookcase I have a stock cut
them clean in half put legs on them and
turn them into TV stand Oh in that
clever now instead of being stuck with
$125 bookcases yeah I got me $250
televisions 200 hey what's the matter
you Harv you're not drinking your
firewater
oh yeah you folding up on us no no no go
right ahead and tell him uh you know
talking about firewater reminds me the
time I was fishing up north on a right
on the shores of this Lake was this old
Indian and he was standing there fished
he pulls himself out of the war up
beautiful little Miroku goodness golly I
didn't
I'd like to dance I would so would I Oh
okay you two dads and happen I'll talk
business oh come on hard we'll talk
business later
oh come on blondie you and I gonna dance
Bobby oh yes honey are you sure
I am yogi of course you are you are not
just how you say twisting my foot honey
ah twisting your foot touching my
stocking pulling your leg no no what's
the matter with these cows today blondie
tells me she's Bush come on Frenchy you
are gonna have little dead feet I'm just
yeah
I'm sure on your deal of course you are
honey I told you well tell him I'm not
getting in the back seat with that that
furniture wolf again okay I'll
straighten out well while you're at it
make sure Colette understands - honey
I'll straighten both out don't you worry
your shiny little no it's a gun
oh it's a Chinese one oh excuse me oh
sorry excuse me
boy boy boy boy I'm missing no path look
blondies lonesome for you yeah she is
yeah
say harp while we get out of here and go
someplace where they play some fast
music okay be right with ya
[Music]
we've him a dance is a wrestling match I
feel sorry for Shirley you mean after
what she just said about to you what did
she say she said you couldn't take
Henderson away from her if you wanted I
do not want to you're gonna let her
insult France so far oh honey she
implied that French women don't have as
much sex appeal as American women we
have more one teacher lesson shall we
when we leave here you jump in the back
seat with headers I just want to see the
look on Jerry's day I do
viva la France leave allophones yeah
but remember I am still your fee oh
don't you worry your shiny little nose
about that Oh Bobby you are them excuse
me my whole huh
[Music]
laughs hey uh hey you have fun well I'm
having a ball say well where the ladies
oh they're there in pattern they're nosy
do you like them they're living dolls
aren't they - just one thing
well hmm which one is mine well I tell
you you can take your pick because
they're fighting over you
I'm sure you noticed the brunette came
into the hotel to getcha
and when he came out front the blonde
was waiting in the back seat boy
yeah yeah that's right two to one we
leave this time the brunette will jump
in the back secret yeah come on harm
they don't have to fight over me if
there's enough for everybody
Oh
you look happy I want to talk to you um
about this phrase you can try all right
now not just a second now there's one
thing I always say pleasure before
business yeah we got a long night ahead
of us buddy Schulte oh hi where's Bobby
we haven't come in yet he hasn't come
home yet what I just stopped by the
house his bed hasn't been slept in well
McVitie's taking Harrison to the airport
no no no I called the hotel they haven't
seen Henderson since 7 o'clock last
night
shooty I worked till midnight getting
this order ready and now I've got no
buyer you check the jail ci the jails
well you know the boss when he
entertains he had her today nice what
you don't even think about things
Oh would you get a cup of coffee come on
I got some of the studio what chilled
you apollo's dreadful what am I gonna do
I can't go to the office I walk in mr.
Ravenal walked up immunities is why is
Henry some signature I turned him loose
here I can't even find Henderson feel
better oh really
guilty where could they be at 9:30 in
the morning there isn't a nightclub in
the world that stays nothing I thought
those mates moved they did Oh wake up
wake up Bobby Bobby where's Henderson
Bobby
haha Henderson Bobby HR Henderson the
furniture King the out-of-town buyer
that you were entertaining for me
ooh Oh out of the the air yeah no
where'd I put ham here was here
yeah but he didn't get away Bobby you
didn't let him leave town no no I
stashed
i stashed him someplace for you mm-hmm I
know looking at in developing tanks
you'll see the developing tank no no no
no wait I remember now he didn't fit no
not hold the heart I've got him I've got
him on ice I am NOT the refrigerator
boys come eating it's good
could you hold it for Chelsea okay could
you hold this stuff please hold this now
hold your breath a char
school breathing
yeah he's improved since I put him in
there all right hey car where's your
cake Bobby do something look me up
Schulte come in here just like half half
blondie wants to dance with you just
watch him right here come on har anyway
dancin this way Bobby how many college
did he go for Tim sorry huh
Bobby 15k oh hold on we get a raise mr.
gray pearl make me a vice president boy
hey better I wouldn't go through another
night look what we got for you just sit
down right over here right that's it
here we are but now right on the bottom
line citizen that's it right this may
harm how'd we wind up here yeah you want
to get your picture taken you remember
something about that oh yeah huh yeah
you know you got it you got to take one
Colin Colin you don't have any say oh
well hey you're Bobby why don't you get
a shot up and sign the order
oh I've always want to ask you how you
use one of these things this kind of
helps a picture 60 seconds it's almost
you open it like this that's a nice set
the exposure there you learn you just
folks it right through there I think
you've got it Harvey while you explain
it so clearly thank you very much boy
yeah we got to get that pictures on no
no right here that's it just take the
pen right there now nice clear
ripping oh let's have a nice big smile I
do I put put put right there I never
smile when I'm buying boy
only when I'm selling
Oh take it last night wouldn't agree
well we had us a ball then we boarded
side foot right there th are hi Jim yeah
Harve did we ever decide which gal was
mine well they were both yours yeah yeah
it sat right there talking house I'd own
the dotted line HR put it right in there
all that blonde was some dancer was it
she looking at she's great
say uh where was that last place I
danced with her I remember the floor was
small but springy yep that was the back
seat of my car yeah just have time to
catch your plane returns I must have a
nice clear signature now yeah I smiled
shop boy I'm having too much fun to go
home
dad hey what ha why don't you call a gal
to let us get an early start tonight
what do you say oh don't worry about
that order boy I made double it now I'd
better get back to the hotel get a
little shut-eye
ah when do you think you'll be dropping
over any minute now
now let me rest till about 5:00 a year
off cause I need my rest that's one day
and I'll tell you something son tonight
we're really gonna hoot it up
[Music]
well it's nice clear picture mr. helm
you want it no I just want him signing
the order good take it heart you'll
never see a better picture of a man
getting the business
[Music]